premier ministre sa parole est à
monsieur gwenaëlle waite
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture et jia ceci mon collègue
philippe gosselin député de la manche
depuis lundi les éleveurs de la manche
bloquent l'accès au mont saint michel
est à l'autoroute a84 entre caen et
rennes
depuis lundi ce mouvement s'étend à
l'ensemble de la normandie et de la
bretagne
cela faisait longtemps très longtemps
que les agriculteurs avaient mené des
actions d'une telle envergure et d'une
telle détermination
cela faisait longtemps aussi monsieur le
ministre que les agriculteurs vous avez
sollicité sans que vous répondiez à
leurs attentes sinon par des opérations
de communication et des effets de manche
vous y avez ajouté depuis lundi le
dédain et le mépris en vous faisant
prier pour enfin rencontrer les
agriculteurs près de deux jours après le
début de leur action
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre vous
êtes au pied du mur monsieur le premier
ministre n'a malheureusement répondu
tout à l'heure à aucune des
interpellations précise de christian
jacob
préférant se réfugier dans l'invectivé
et dans la politique politicienne
vous n'avez pas non plus ce matin
monsieur le ministre
répondu au désespoir des agriculteurs
vous ne pouvez pas vous limiter à des
réponses conjoncturelles
alors que la crise est structurelle vous
ne pouvez pas vous limiter à des aides
de trésorerie et à des reports de
charges alors que le sujet porte sur la
fixation des prix et la répartition des
marges
vous ne pouvez pas continuer à mépriser
les agriculteurs qui ne demandent pas
l'aumône mais seulement la possibilité
de vivre normalement de leur travail
au delà des opérations de communication
et d'essai et des effets de manche
vous devez donner à la représentation
nationale et aux éleveurs des réponses
de fond vers les filières lait
maintiennent dans devine et viande
porcine et vous devez également vous
engager sur les échéances de leur mise
en oeuvre
si vous n'en êtes pas capables alors
dites-nous quand vous allez mettre fin à
vos fonctions ministérielles la parole
est à monsieur stéphane le foll mini
d'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la faune
se présentant au niveau de la réponse
plusieurs monsieur le député je vais
vous rappeler d'abord que il ya déjà pas
mal d'années d'ailleurs j'ai commencé
par un bts agricole que si ici dans
l'assemblée il ya quelqu'un qui connaît
l'agriculture et qui aurait pu devenir
leader j'en suis je voudrais monsieur le
député aussi vous rappeler une phrase
qui ramènera l'état d'esprit qui était
celui de la majorité il ya quelques
années lors d'un 20h a été dit par le
premier ministre de l'époque la
multiplication des grandes surfaces et
des magasins hard discount permettra de
stimuler la concurrence pour renforcer
la croissance et grâce à la baisse des
prix une réponse à la question
lancinante pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens sera répondu le pouvoir
d'achat voilà ce qui a été dit à 1 20
heures il ya quelques années et qui n'a
suscité à l'époque monsieur le député
aucune remarque ni de monsieur jacob qui
avait pourtant été président du cnj a pu
un temps ni je l'imaginais monsieur des
députés de votre part quand vous parlez
de la question des prix ce qui a été
fait à ce moment là quoique vous en
pensiez et je comprends que vous vouliez
surtout pas qu'on en parle ça a un
impact aujourd'hui est qu'il faut
redresser une situation que vous avez
créé et qui prend du temps quand moi je
fais une réunion le 17 juin à mon
initiative pour réunir autour d'une
table tous les acteurs et leur expliquer
qu'on ne peut plus continuer à baisser
des prix
je répond exactement le contraire de ce
que vous disiez il y a cinq ans voilà la
différence entre moi aujourd'hui milices
de l'agriculture et d'autres ministres
de l'agriculture entre ce que nous
faisons est ce que vous avez fait merci
monsieur